the US Navy rushed to assist two tankers
in the Middle East damaged in an
apparent attack overnight the incidents
took place in the Gulf of Oman near the
Strait of Hormuz pictures from Iranian
state media reportedly showed two ships
one Japanese and one Norwegian on fire
after the attack David Martin is at the
Pentagon with what the u.s. and Iran are
saying David good morning good morning a
US defense official is saying it is
highly likely these attacks were caused
by Iran he is not able to describe the
method of attack but crew members of the
two ships are being quoted as saying
they thought they had either struck a
mine or been hit by torpedoes this
contradicts what iran's Foreign Minister
is saying he tweeted that these
explosions were beyond suspicious
suggesting they had been the work of
some third party in an attempt to
sabotage a visit by japan's Prime
Minister to Tehran he is there today in
an effort to reduce tensions in the
Middle East the US defense official is
also saying that Iranian claims to have
rescued all 44 crew members are patently
false because 21 of the crew members
were picked up by the u.s. Navy now in
recent weeks there have been other
attacks on tankers in the Gulf of Oman
just outside the Persian Gulf and those
previous attacks those were carried out
by minds placed on the halls of the ship
and the u.s. blamed Iran for that the
u.s. did not retaliate for those attacks
but it has warned Iran it will be held
accountable for any attacks on American
interests and the free passage of ships
in and out of the Persian Gulf certainly
qualifies as
American interests and so much of the
world depends on that oil Anthony David
Martin at the Pentagon Thanks